So the question is,
how do you differentiate the utility of
behavioral slash psychotherapeutic
treatments for conditions like
depression versus medical treatments?
Okay,
so the first thing I would say is don't
underestimate the utility of medical
interventions.
Depression is a catastrophe.
It carries with it a very high suicide
rate and it also levels people out and
it's really hard on their families and
so and it and it's physiologically
extraordinarily damaging.
And so if you're in a depressive state
and it's severe,
you can try an antidepressant.
You'll know in a month if it works,
if it works well,
maybe it'll help you get your life
together.
Like we could say,
well maybe you're depressed because your
life isn't very well together.
Could be.
Sometimes people are depressed,
their life is just,
it isn't fine because no one's life is
fine.
Everyone's life is a tragedy.
But sometimes people have their lives in
order,
as much as you could expect anyone to
have.
They have friends,
they have an intimate relationship,
they have a career that they like,
you know,
they're,
they're qualified industrious people
working hard on what they're doing.
And,
and,
and really playing a minimum number of
games with themselves and they're
terribly depressed,
antidepressant man that sometimes that
will just fix it.
And so hooray,
you were biological entity.
If,
if there's something out there that can
help you strengthen yourself so that you
can prevail.
Great.
And you know,
people,
you hear,
everyone takes antidepressants,
you know,
everyone's taking them.
It's like no one takes those bloody
things without serious consideration.
Half the time I spend with my clients
who are depressed is often the two years
long attempt to get them to tentatively
try an antidepressant because there are
so guilty that they're relying on an
external crutch to sort out their lives
that they can't even tolerate it.
But you know,
I say,
well look man,
what if you had diabetes,
you know are going to take your insulin.
It's like you got stressed,
you blew out at your weakest point.
That's what happens when you get
stressed.
If there's something out there that
might help you,
it's like try it for God's sake.
You'll know in a month and you'd just
stop if it doesn't work.
Now,
having said that,
you want to do a multidimensional
analysis,
it's like,
well,
do you have any friends?
Do you have an intimate relationship?
Are you pursuing one?
Do you have a reasonable career?
Are you as educated as you are?
Intelligent?
You have something useful to do with
your time outside of work?
Do you have a drug or alcohol problem?
Are there other behavioral issues like
sleep dysregulation and lack of eating
that are contributing to the pathology?
You want to differentiate all of that
and wherever you can make a behavioral
intervention so much the better,
but sometimes too,
you're dealing with people whose lives
are so that they don't even know where
to start.
They're different than the ones who have
everything in order.
See,
and you say,
well,
try this man.
Maybe you won't cut your throat in the
next month because if your dad,
it's going to be hard to work with you,
and so,
so medical interventions,
anything.
If you're sick,
you do what's necessary to get better
and you your pride behind.
If you.
If you have to,
and that says nothing about the utility
of the behavioral interventions,
you want to hit the problem with
everything you have at your disposal,
but some antidepressants especially,
especially for people whose lives are
together and who are depressed,
antidepressants can be absolutely
miraculous.
So you know when you hear about the
clinical evidence in their favor being
iffy,
and that's partly because the diagnosis
of depression isn't very well
formulated,
that it's very different to have a
terrible life than to be depressed and
antidepressants can only help you so
much if you have a terrible life.
So yeah.